from the moment he came down that shiny
escalator in Trump Tower Donald Trump
represented an existential threat to the
DC swamp
he promised to end the cycle of
corruption throughout the government to
make it leaner and more accountable to
the people and he even took on some of
the sacred cows you trust intelligence
not so much from the people that have
been doing it for our country I mean
look what's happened over the last 10
years look what's happened over the
years I mean it's been catastrophic and
in fact I won't use some of the people
that are sort of your standards you know
just use them use them use them very
easy to use them but I won't use them
because they've made such bad decisions
yeah he had the nerve to call out the
Intel community aka the deep state as
part of the problem well Trump believe
that everything in Washington had become
politicized bloated and unmanageable and
what we take away from the now public
house Intel committee memo that was
released today it's that Donald Trump
once again was right when the American
people think of the FBI in the
Department of Justice they can have
faith that the agency's leadership use
their vast powers without political bias
or animus in other words you shouldn't
be able to investigate or surveil any
American without clear probable cause
that a crime has been committed and by
the way in order to secure a Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act or FISA
warrant the government must also find
that the person targeted in this case
mr. Carter page was acting as a foreign
agent or on behalf of a foreign
government but I'll tell you this after
reading this memo today I don't know how
the FBI even met that benchmark now
apparently those requirements those
statutory requirements went out the
window because they had to take out
Trump by any means necessary
the FBI used a minor figure on the Trump
advisory board the affer mention mr.
page
an attempt to penetrate Trump's inner
circle now Paige had been on the FBI's
radar for his activities in Russia long
before his name was listed in that
campaign press release in the spring of
2016 but then on October 21st 2016 the
FBI filed an application with the FISA
Court for a warrant to surveil Paige
according to the house Intel memo they
submitted that phony Russian dossier
caried created by British spy
Christopher Steele as their primary
evidence now the document itself was
filled with conjecture and
unsubstantiated assertions about Russian
efforts to cozy up to them businessman
and now candidate Donald Trump now we've
known for some time that the dossier was
funded by the DNC and the Clinton
campaign in the FBI in the DOJ knew it
too but here's the rub even though they
know the political origins of the
dossier the FBI did not tell the FISA
Court neither did the DOJ they would go
on to secure three FISA surveillance
renewals on Carter page all based on
that same dossier Oppo research in other
words the FISA warrants were approved by
FBI director James Comey deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe acting Attorney
General Sally Yates and deputy AG rod
Rosenstein there are so many lapses and
biases at play here it's frankly hard to
keep track of them but we're gonna do
our best we know the FBI authorized
payment for the man at the center of
this entire opus chrissteele for
information in that dossier and to be
clear Steele was like hardly an
objective source when it came to
national security matters he's quoted in
the house Intel memo as telling DOJ
officials that he was quote desperate
the Donald Trump not get elected and was
passionate about him not being president
oh no agenda there whatsoever so he
cooks up
fake dossier to try to kill Trump's
candidacy and at the same time still
began shooting his mouth off to Yahoo
News about Carter pages trip to Moscow
which he included in as infamous dossier
the FBI later cites that yahoo news
story as corroborating evidence of the
dossiers credibility that's a neat trick
so a story about the dossier is
corroboration of the story itself which
is fake fantastic
the bureau put all of that in their FISA
requests to continue their surveillance
of page now it's here here's where it
really gets good a month after the FBI
used Steele's dossier and the fake news
he leaked to get the FISA warrant they
realized steel is leaking confidential
information to the media and divulging
his relationship for the FBI so the FBI
terminated its relationship with him so
here's the upshot the predicate for the
entire Trump Russia collusion canard the
prevailing evidence advanced to surveil
page which would lead to the creation of
the Muller investigation and all the
madness that followed was built on the
foundation of the fake steel dossier
paid for by Hillary Clinton's campaign
and the DNC here is Devon Nunez from the
house Intel committee a short time ago
and just step back for a moment this is
not trying to go after some terrorists
then they got a warrant on someone in
the Trump campaign using opposition
research paid for by the Democratic
Party and the Hillary Clinton campaign
that's what this is about and it's wrong
and it should never be done and the
Democrats who have long been suspicious
of the overreach and the bias of law
enforcement it's funny they believe now
that law enforcement can do no wrong
they could never be questioned they're
always right the left did sound like a
chorus protesting the memos revelations
today each of these allegations is at
best cherry picked and it worse just
simply not at all in
of the bias that the Republicans are
trying to allege it's likely
cherry-picked and we know what happens
when you cherry-pick information who
knows what it might have been FISA
application and you cherry-pick in the
summary two points that you don't like
why should the FBI and the intelligence
community trust our committee or
Congress with sensitive and classified
information if they think we're on a
party-line basis going to vote to
cherry-pick and disclose parts of it I'd
like a drinking game on a Friday night
cherry picker we were really trashed
Russian collusion remember was
supposedly the concern that drove the
FBI to apply for that surveillance
warrant so they worried that the
election would be disputed disrupted
well I contend that this surveillance
itself was designed to disrupt the
election how is this done first as an
insurance policy against Trump's winning
and later as an effort to undo the
election and upend the presidency what
the memo makes clear there was collusion
after all you bet the collusion was
between the Comey FBI the Obama Justice
Department and the Hillary Clinton
campaign and that's the angle